sì faremo un video pazzesco epico
andremo fare un piccolo scherzetto al
nostro cagnolino per il e vedremo come
reagisce praticamente vitale si
travestirà da sauro ora non stiamo
insieme
parlino stato faticoso formento capisce
l'altra messi uno dall altro poi entrerà
in camera che fa finta di essere molto
spaventata come se fosse un vero un
altro che entra in casa e vediamo a
berlino cosa fosse di proteggere certa
che ladro o tele famiglia di niente se
si nasconde dietro di me mi vieni come
potrebbe reagire
secondo me pronto vi ringraziamo perché
questa è l'idea che ci avete dato poi
siamo ha descritto nei commenti
riprovare a fare questo esperimento
questo scherzetto con berlino e vedere
come reagisce
ci è sembrato l'idea portasti ca anche
perché siamo super curiosi di vedere
come reagisce
quindi mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace se volete vedere altri scherzetti
giochi con merlino mimica voti prendete
i pop corn e e iniziamo prepararsi per
lo scherzetto merlino come sempre a
quest'ora lui dorme alle orecchie tutte
tirate in su oggi ogni fatto ce le ha
tirate giù quindi tanto tirate in su non
so come che rimarranno poi da grande
curate quanto è cresciuto c'è
grandissimo merlino non sa quello che la
stessa legge il suo giochino o sicilia
dormi tranquillo verdi lì noi siamo
quello che sei stato
[Musica]
ok andiamo a vestire vitale dall'altro
adesso allora eccoci qua siamo in camera
perché se non berlino ci sente e vuole
entrare tanto allora per fare il
passamontagna ovviamente non solo
abbiamo quindi useremo del black out
questo non mi e calzamaglia vitale la
metà in testa e ritagliamo due buchi per
gli occhi
ora andiamo parlando telegate implicarsi
st cambiato e sta mettendo dei vestiti
che non ha mai inverso prima così non
c'è un solo motore nei vestiti così
speriamo che nessuno si accorga che vi
ho dimenticata di prendere le forbici
quindi devo tornare in camera e
prenderle cercando di non svegliare il
nostro inizia a seguire
[Musica]
ecco sei vestito tutto di nero
però allora bruciata questo scaldacollo
però non basta merlino lo riconoscerebbe
da sopra quindi tokyo mette bella okc
orecchie da coniglio riconosco ti fai
paura forse qui tenendo così no è meglio
meglio tagliare due buchi per gli occhi
esce un vitale così così un po ora io mi
riconosce penso che ti riconosce
dobbiamo tagliare i buchi neri ho acceso
come non è troppo piccolo non lo so
tutti qui si beh mi sembra un po piccolo
panino fatto bene fai paura
il nostro con le orecchie da coniglio
ora io vado a posizionare tutte le
camere e in più vitale avrà una camera
che terrà con lo stesso allora nel fine
sta ancora dormendo
e ora posiziono le camere così
riprendiamo la reazione allora prima
camera da posizionare o quella che le
mie più antica pelle le adoro prima
camera questa è la camera digitale
grazie indiavolate prima camera così
sfilata che la prima camera sarà marco
si riprenderà il tutto berlino sta
ancora dormendo
e poi la seconda camera star acqua e poi
vitale ne avrà una borsa di nuove tele
se vitale è pronto belino motivato armi
le chitarre sta sistemando la camera che
sarà qua cosi riprenderà il tutto
provate indovinare i miei commenti come
reagirà a berlino scrivete orami con me
ok ragazzi seconda camera e tutto pronto
merlino starebbero meglio allora quello
che farò io starò a letto far finta di
guardare il telefono
poi quando entrerà vitale cioè il draw
il ladro io farò finta di esser super
spaventata proverò urlare essere
disperata altrimenti ovviamente berlino
penserà che sia un mio amico
devo fargli capire che è un intruso
vedremo server
i nomi difenderà comunque non vi
preoccupate è tutto finto
non mi starà facendo niente vitale farà
finta appunto di tirarmi di fare
qualcosa non vi preoccupate sto bene
tutto finto
staremo recitando quindi non vi
preoccupate siete pronti a vedere come
andrà
preparatevi e iniziamo perché marino si
è svegliato sarà un film iago e gli
faccio finta di mettermi qua e stare
tranquilla quella del telefono casinò
[Musica]
allora vitale al mio stato impostato
uscendo dalla porta e rientrando questi
imbelli innocente che qualcuno è entrato
dalla porta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no perché io mi salvato marino e
ricattato scodinzolini a berlino il
modulo berlino ahia ahia ahia ahia
[Musica]
e avrebbe vissuto
allora penso che berlino vi ha
riconosciuto vittoria in qualche modo
sono io
giovedì capito fregava niente fregava
niente adesso visto che niente
spaventato un pochino tipologiche
abbiamo scoperto che se entrasse un
ladro in casa merlino o di dover ebbe
ben berlino insomma non mi misi piede
tagli anche un pochino avuto questa è la
proposta così come si era appena
svegliato ha detto barone voglia di
combattere
oppure mi ha riconosciuto fin da subito
sentire forse ti ha riconosciuto da
subito infatti a volte scodinzola ma
anche quindi forza ti ha riconosciuto
dall odore non lo so scrivete voi nei
commenti secondo voi se non gliene
fregava niente off è riuscito a
riconoscere vitale in qualche modo
inviate conosciuto era un po confuso
e stato comunque super divertente
magari possiamo provare rifarlo con
un'altra persona che non sia vitale la
persona che magari lui non ha mai visto
e vedere come reagisce merlino ecco così
lungo è diventato enorme corapi che
lungo merlina il tuo sguardo migliore
mamma mia siamo nati stanchi e io pure
di stage siamo stati capiti faccio i
grattini della pancia muove la zampetta
perché si fa male dico allora noi ci
siamo divertiti un sacco a fare questo
scherzo non ci aspettavamo questa
reazione da berlino speravo che almeno
mi proteggesse un pochettino deve
proteggere potremmo anche provare il
contrario in cui vitale la vittima
magari la protegge di più
scriveteci nei commenti cosa ne pensate
di questo reazioni di merlino secondo
voi perchè ha reagito così perché un
cane dell'errore noi interessa di a
staccare fregati come volevo mangiare i
tappeti anche partito ha redditi intanto
mangiano il proprio gusto bruciato suo
padrone proprio come il suo padrone e
tutto si guarda ai mezzi siamo divertiti
un binario a fare kurt che si è
divertito tantissimo ho vinto un osso
tutelate chiara sorella ecco qualche
merlino viene in grembo allora molto dir
in grembo dopo che non mi promettono
berlino ma che sappia guardare romanzi
fra decine di conventi che altri video
volete vedere lo stato e mi piace se
volete vedere altri video del genere e
ora vi lasciamo qua 4 castellini e su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione
[Musica]